la situation dans les hôpitaux où est
pas est pas catastrophique dans
l'instant par exemple dans mon hôpital
il ya très peu de patients atteints du
coup l'idée d'un marais animations il y
en a pas donc on a on a des raisons de
s'inquiéter sur une cinquième vague sûr
on a des raisons oui on a des raisons de
s'inquiéter mais est ce qu'on peut
craindre le pire je pense que le pire
est derrière d'accord qui font de
rassurer ce serait quoi le pire alors
maintenant les spectateurs mal à nous on
aime bien comme ça c'est bien vrai nom
mais il répond j'adore michel
vaccination des regards s'il vous plaît
laissez le parler après non mais les
gars là ne partiront après
le pire et vous donnera le deyrolle et
gardant le rythme
il ya une immunité collective qui est en
train de s'installer 2 par les
contaminations dues comme ça d'une part
et d'autre part grâce à la vaccination
et voilà et donc
nous ne nous nous n'avons pas et à la
toilette nous n'avons pas actuellement
les chiffres qui sont corrélés des
chiffres de mortalité qui sont corrélés
avec la corde avec les chiffres de
contamination que nous avions il ya elle
est on peut le faire comme en quelques
mois c'est à dire confiner les non
vaccinés bah écoutez c'est une rupture
de l'égalité républicaine
on peut pas le faire c'est franchement
et puis déjà nokia autriche ils n'ont
pas dit non mais l'autriche à la france
notre vision est basique est différent
c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai lieberman a
raconté la grotte de gérard oui tu es
venu pour parler confie sous pour
aller je fais une petite une rumeur veut
dire bien fait girard donc ya pas de
raison de s'inquiéter comme a
complètement je fais partie des repas
merci d'être venus les gars allure
mais non l'alarmé a dit gérard mais non
on est quand même et là je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec le confrère ce serait
une rupture grave de la mieux assurée
donc c'est impossible
là on a tellement une chose qui était
impossible il ya déjà je n'irai pas
jusque là y'a des fous un club comme il
a des déclenché comme une grande folie
parmi nos élites et on a vu toute une
série de mesures qui sont dangereuses je
vous voyez le passe par exemple là on le
passe ils ont fait le pas ce lundi en
autriche habitent ici un nom à la
loterie choix de l'hôtel chez bouza
tasse en a 4 mois de recul et là vous
avez la courbe d'hier ah ouais de l oms
depuis le passé ils ont augmenté le
nombre de contaminations quotidienne par
sang commence à ses commandes explique
ça chez moi chez toi sur un imac signer
là bas on ne sait pas si son absence
de
scénario plus après les ja la tôle à
parlons après les médecins à bord oui
merci
l'autriche les pays de l'est sont
beaucoup moins vacciner que la france
sur l'allemagne que l'angleterre c'est
normal cette courbe
ce qui est énorme ce qui est normal
c'est que quand vous n'êtes pas quand la
vaccination n'a pas touché une grande
partie de la population vous avez des
contaminations qui sont en hausse alors
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
pourquoi il ya une inquiétude pourquoi
actuellement on dit qu'il va avoir une
cinquième bague pour pour actuellement
dit que ça sert travailler l'osier
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui mais byron
études vous savez ou non mais parce que
non mais vous vous rangez gianni versace
on est dans le nord mais vous disent
qu'il faut pas s'inquiéter moi pardon je
m'inquiète je vois que sar confine en
europe c'est vrai le vin au confinement
il a été employé ce week-end par gabri
la tête rien n'est à exclure voilà la
raison et le pardon mais je trouve ça
honteux aubenas raison deux ans ça fait
deux ans que les français obéit sagement
au confinement aux gestes barrières au
bon dieu et aux vaccins et on nous
reparle de confinement deux ans après
mais c'est honteux honteux à quoi ça
sert de se faire vacciner
dire ce à quoi ça sert de se vacciner
pour entendre le mot pour finement deux
ans après on se dit alors si aucun nom
mais il n'exclut rien non il n'exclut
rien normal il ya un confinement des non
vaccinés de fait le pari vaccinale ça
écoute ça équivaut un confinement et
c'est vrai dd non vaccinés quand elle
est à thaksin et vous verrez bien le
droit d'aller au restaurant vous n'avez
pas le droit d'aller au vous avez une
passion voilà et est à will say on pay
en mai mais c'est contraignant vous
imaginez chaque sens que vous allez au
restaurant il faut il faut vous faire le
test et le film ayant mais là je sais
pas bye bye donc alors la politique du
gouvernement c'est d'inciter au maximum
les français à se faire vacciner y as et
c'est quoi cette histoire de doses en
plus là cette histoire de d'autant plus
cette idée a des études qui ont montré
que il y avait une diminution de
l'immunité mais ça six mois voilà donc
c'est le riz vaccin il il est bon six
mois c'est à dire qu'on va se faire
vacciner de même pas six mois à partir
de 4 mois il commence à baisser voilà la
belle vie commence à baisser il est
franchement inefficace et six mois
d'accord vous êtes vacciné vous je ne
répondrai ce que veux tu as le sia a
fait sien est-ce que tu as le sida
date a donné une notion de secret
médical moi je te réponds la même chose
c'est le secret médical
25 4 mois alors c'est les chiffres c'est
les chiffres actuels de tous les gens
qui étudient le vaccin sérieusement et
je rappelle que le taux d'efficacité
dans la bonne période ce que tu as un
panaris
non
non mais j'estime que ça c'est un sacré
médical que je
comprends je suis d'accord avec toi là
tu fais ce que je veux c'est à dire le
secret médical non le nagorno remis à
l'eau vautours n'est pas le sien eh bien
oui mais chahuté sur j'avais trois dos
tel 3 12 voilà bah très bien
rouen donc aujourd'hui il faut faire la
troisième dose c'est le nom il faut
n'ont cessé ses biens à ses credo il ya
une incitation voilà c'est ça la 3e tour
vous africain d'affaires pour les 50-65
ans et il ya une obligation pour les
plus de 65 ans en fait comme si vous le
faites pas vous n'avez plus votre pass
sanitaires